(gentle music)
- Some cheese, miss?
- Yes, please, thank you.
- Great.
Just tell me when to stop.
- Yeah.
(playful music increases in intensity)
- I'll tell you when I want you to stop.
- Okay.
(fun music)
- It's you.
- Ooh, you guys want pizza for lunch?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Oh, I can't have pizza;
I'm lactose intolerant.
(cries out in alarm)
- (groans) That smells awful.
- Yeah, that's how you know it's good.
- You really put cheese
on everything, don't you?
- Yeah.
(dramatic classical music)
- Is that cheese on cheese?
(fun music)
- Can I add cheese to that?
Can I add cheese to that?
- [Man] And would you
like cheese with that?
- (laughs) Jake, you crazy boy.
Do I want cheese with that, you crazy.
See you at pick up!
- I think I'm gonna name
my first daughter Brie.
- You think I can name my kid Manchego?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- That's a cool name.
- Can I get you anything?
- What kind of cheese do you have?
- So, Miss Brunson, you
are in excellent health.
- Oh, thank goodness.
- Oh, and we also found
the source of your stomach issues.
- Okay, what is it?
- Did you know you were
lactose intolerant?
(dramatic music)
Your blood has a deficiency in lactase--
- No.
- Which is the enzyme--
- No, no, no, no, no.
- That allows you
to digest dairy.
- No!
No, no, no!
Cheese, cheese, cheese,
cheese, where's the cheese?
(screams)
(gasping)
- What is it, Quinta?
- I just had the worst dream.
It started off so relatable.
(fun music)
- What is this?
- Cheese.
- What?
- You said you wanted cheese.
- The fuck is this?
- You said you wanted cheese!
- Kraft singles?
What do you think I am, 12 years old?
Are you kidding me?
- It's cheese!
- How dare you disgrace me
with the cheese of a peasant?
Get out, get out!
This is not my apartment.